so now more than ever the u.s needs a
strong forceful clear thinking leader
who is able willing uh and committed to
defending our great american way of life
and willing to stand up
to the hostile regimes america's
interests in a world stage
no matter what unfortunately sippy cup
joe he's obviously not that leader
he can't even stand up to the extreme
destructive force of his
forces inside his own party
here with a little message to uh joe
sippy cup
he's asleep right now maybe you'll hear
about it tomorrow uh with reaction he
has his brand new book out you see that
book
that book will be the way out of this
mess called american marxism the host of
uh
life liberty and levin the number one
show here on sunday night on the fox
news channel
i understand mr levin that you have a
message for sippy cup
you know sean is a couple things i want
to say to mr sippy cup
number one he is the human pandemic i
said he is
i want to address something very
specifically to joe biden and his party
this poison of anti-semitism
is growing in your party and your
silence isn't going to fix it
talib who in my opinion is an out of the
closet anti-semite
and she's joined by 20 or 30 others
of the hard marxist hamas wing of the
democrat party you have omar and aoc and
presley and bush you have bernie sanders
i don't care how bernie sanders
identifies it's irrelevant
the democrats in the house of
representatives
voted unanimously against sanctioning
hamas
last week during the time when hamas was
firing four thousand missiles into
israel
now joe biden sees this he sees on tv
individuals with antifa-like clothing
with the palestinian flag chasing down
jews
in cities throughout this country in
cars
attacking jews organized like black
lives matter and antifa
beating jews graffiti on synagogues
including swastikas and so forth we
haven't seen anything like this
and i don't know ever the fbi says 60
percent of all
anti-religious hate crimes is against
jews the jews are a tiny percentage of
the population
what did chuck schumer say about this
who's jewish from new york
i didn't hear him say anything if he
said anything he did it under his breath
what did the speaker of the house nancy
pelosi say about it i didn't hear her
say anything if she did it was under her
breath
joe biden had to be lobbied by liberal
jewish groups to do something
on friday and finally saturday put out a
statement
what did the attorney general say
nothing that i'm aware of
how about the cabinet secretary that
runs homeland security what did he say
nothing that i heard of how about the
fbi director
who says white supremacy is the great
danger in this country
is he blind to what's taking place no
this is frightening
and it's happening all over the world
but to be happening in the united states
of america
is absolutely appalling and i blame the
democrat party
because the democrat party is stirring
this stuff up
you have members in the democrat party
that are tweeting things and putting
things on facebook that are
absolutely bigoted and anti-semitic
about israel and the jews it's a tiny
little country it's the only jewish
state on the face of the earth
and arabs in israel have more liberties
more due process rights more property
rights more
more legal rights than jews do in
any country in any muslim
or arab society which means they have
none
so this is quite appalling to me and at
the same time this is going on you have
democrats embracing black lives matter
which is a hate america marxist
anarchist
violent organization that also is
anti-semitic and backs the bds movement
and we have democrat mayors across this
country painting black lives matter not
black lives matter the group black lives
matter on their streets
and promoting it you have corporations
embracing them
you have lebron james and sports stars
espn sportscasters embracing it
it is a disgusting appalling thing
that's going on in this country right
now
and in the media the new york times and
the washington post both of which
did the best they could to censor the
holocaust this is the best they can do
to make to make light of this to defend
black lives matter and pretend these
sorts of things aren't going on
this is a a shocking event that's taking
place
so i wanted to say to joe biden what the
hell are you going to do about this
our prior president donald trump was a
strong supporter
against anti-semitism against
anti-semitism a strong
supporter of the jewish community and
what's going on in this country is a
disgusting
disgrace that we've allowed these
marxist
leftists and others to do what they're
doing pushing critical race theory
another racist theory joe biden is
funding critical race theory to go into
our classrooms
this is separatist nationalist black
panther 1960s
crap that they're trying to put into the
minds of our children
what the hell is going on in this
country with that party
i want to save a minute or two for my
dear friend president trump
this democrat party adopts the worst
policies
the world has ever seen they're acting
like the
soviet communist party in the city of
new york in the state of new york where
they go after politicians
and former officials they don't agree
with here's tonight's headline
new grand jury seated for next stage of
trump investigation
trump investigation donald trump
is a multi-billionaire he has multiple
corporations
so what are they trying to do to donald
trump
they're digging into his tax returns
they're threatening his longtime
financial officer
they're going after his son and the
divorce that
took place with his former wife they're
interrogating them
they're trying to pressure them to do
anything they can
to find a gift tax violation to find
some other tax violation
the fed's already investigated trump
clean
now the politicians the democrat party
in new york and the state
you have an attorney general who's a
complete hack leticia james
she came into offer saying she was going
to go after trump you have this
manhattan district attorney cyrus vance
who's a real punk a political hack who's
done a lot of things that are highly
questionable
and i want the american people to
understand they're trying to drag this
president our president trump in front
of this grand
jury a democrat party democrat city
democrat state
to find something anything that they can
use against him
because they don't want him to run for
office again
and they are trying to destroy him
joseph stalin would be very proud of you
democrats in new york
i must say i'm disgusted with the
democrat party
and i am disgusted with these hacks in
new york and that
is it great one mark levine see that
book american marxism
gonna lead hopefully this country back
to life
he's on every week night every sunday
night rather uh life liberty levin
8 p.m on the fox news channel when we
come back hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else